Je n'ai jamais vu un film comme celui-ci,
nous sommes en train de vous donner tout ce que nous
avons,
nous avons quelque chose de spécial, alors
célébrons que c'est la fin de la route,
alors nous revenons aux racines de Fast
and Furious
Braves
alors je vais  dans quel genre de problème pouvons-nous
avoir cette fois tout est
plus grand et vous frappe comme une main droite de
la mâchoire
c'est True Entertainment sur une
toile massive vous êtes sur le point d'apprendre tout sur la
peur avec un nouveau méchant avec de nouveaux Stakes
vrais steaks  Je n'ai pas joué un méchant
depuis probablement 10 ans, d'accord, les idiots,
qu'est-ce qu'on fait exploser, je voulais apporter
quelque chose à la lignée qui n'avait pas
encore été fait, il vient juste avec des armes
flamboyantes, vous allez en enfer
Dante en est vraiment un  un gars en colère mais vraiment
bien habillé pour affronter Dom et
sa famille tu devais être un certain
psychotique il vient pour toi avec
tout il y a
quelque chose qui arrive et Dom le sait
je ne peux pas penser à un meilleur moment pour
lui d'être à la croisée des chemins  ne jamais accepter
cela
et la souffrance est ancienne, nous ne nous sentons tous pas
sûrs en ce moment, même en bas, c'est
Sarah, nous n'avons pas eu autant de
succès que nous avons l'habitude de voir cette
équipe et c'est un peu effrayant,
cela prépare le terrain pour quelque chose de plus grand
donc c'est un territoire inconnu c'est le
problème d'avoir une si grande famille
comment choisissez-vous ceux que vous sauvez
est-ce
angoissant ouais c'est la
magie de la course rapide c'est l'heure du spectacle c'est
le début de la fin c'est
la somme de tout ce que nous avons aimé dans l'
univers Fast and Furious ici ils viennent
c'est excitant d'être un morceau dedans  le
puzzle de quelque chose qui est si
important dans la culture pop que je suggère
au public de se préparer c'est un
gros problème pour qu'une saga soit complète elle
doit avoir une fin c'est doux-amer mais
oserais-je dire plus significatif